Almost two years after the
slap heard 'round the world,
Jada Pinkett Smith is speaking out about both
the incident and her marriage to Will Smith.
While promoting her new book "Worthy," which
hits shelves on October 17, Pinkett Smith sat
down with People to reveal something huge about
the viral Oscars moment where Will Smith slapped
presenter Chris Rock after Rock made a joke
about Pinkett Smith's shaved head. Pinkett
Smith lives with alopecia and chooses to keep
her head shaved as a result. Needless to say,
a "G.I. Jane" joke made by Rock didn't go
over well. Smith famously followed up the
slap by telling Rock, quote, "Keep my
wife's name out your f---ing mouth."
Accord to Pinkett Smith, she simply assumed
the situation was a planned bit ... and was
just as shocked as anybody to discover that Smith
actually slapped Rock in earnest. She told People,
"I thought, 'This is a skit. I was like,
'There's no way that Will hit him.' It
wasn't until Will started to walk back to his
chair that I even realized it wasn't a skit."
The moment was definitely shocking, and
it led to huge consequences for Smith — so
it's an added surprise to hear that Pinkett
Smith was apparently baffled by it too. She
also revealed that the first thing she asked Smith
following the ceremony was simply, "Are you okay?"
That moment when Will Smith slapped Chris Rock
back in March 2022 was incredibly confusing at
first — in fact, several feeds of the ceremony
went completely blank as networks panicked.
But when the dust settled, all hell really
broke loose. Shortly after slapping Rock,
Smith got up on the stage to accept his award
for best actor for his role in "King Richard,"
a film about Venus and Serena Williams' father
Richard Williams. The anointed winner then gave
an extraordinarily tearful speech and
received a standing ovation. However,
Smith started facing major
consequences almost immediately.
"When I open my eyes I didn't realize, I
was like 'Why is everyone so quiet?' Like,
I literally was not present
for that whole entire moment."
Not only was there reportedly an argument
over whether or not to kick Smith out of
the ceremony on the spot, but Smith also
resigned from the Academy (he'd been a
member since 2001) and was eventually
banned from the ceremony for ten full
years. In response, Smith released
a simple, brief statement that said,
"I accept and respect the Academy's decision."
Smith's next movie, "Emancipation," barely made a
splash when it came out in 2022, and a sequel to
his Netflix original movie "Bright" was canceled.
Smith may have walked away from the ceremony with
a statuette for best actor, but the effect this
slap had on his career still feels irreversible.
Rock, meanwhile, took some time to comment
on the slap but ultimately addressed
the incident in a Netflix stand-up
special titled "Selective Outrage."
"People are like, 'Did it hurt?' It still hurts!
I've got 'Summertime' ringing in my ears."
Jada Pinkett Smith had one last bombshell
to drop in her People interview. Even
though Will Smith implored Chris Rock to
keep his "wife's" name out of his mouth,
the couple has actually been separated
since 2016. Pinkett Smith told People
after revealing that the two were
long separated at the 2022 Oscars,
"We're still figuring it out. We've been doing
some really heavy-duty work together. We just
got deep love for each other and we are going
to figure out what that looks like for us."
With that said, she also clarified that
she and Smith are there for one another
as much as they can be. Regarding the slap
and its ramifications, Pinkett Smith said,
"I'm going to be by his side but also allow
him to have to figure this out for himself."
Pinkett Smith's memoir, which might
give people even more insight into
her marriage and the infamous
slap, comes out on October 17.